let's say I have a subspace V that is
equal to all of the vectors all the
vectors let me write it this way all of
the X 1 X 2 X 3
so all the vectors like this that
satisfy that satisfy X 1 plus X 2 plus X
3 is equal to 0 so if you think about it
this is just a plane in r3 so this
subspace is a plane in r3 and I'm
interested in finding the transformation
matrix for the projection for the
projection of any vector X and r3 onto V
so how can we do that so we can do it
like we did in the last video we can
find the basis for this the subspace
right there and that's not too hard to
do we could say x1 if we assume that
let's say that X 2 and X 3 are kind of
free variables and we could say X 1 is
equal to minus X 2 minus X 3 and then
let's just just so that we can write it
in kind of our parametric form or if we
can write our solution set as the
combination of basis vectors we can say
X 2 X 2 is equal to let's say it's equal
to some arbitrary constant C 2 and let's
say that X 3 is equal to some arbitrary
constant C 3 then we can say that then
we can say that V we can rewrite V we
could say that V is I'll do it here V is
equal to the set of all X 1 X 2 s and X
3 s that are equal to C 2 times so X 1
is equal to minus let me write let me
rewrite this let me rewrite this with
the SI toos this is equal to C 2 this is
equal to C 3 so X 1 is equal to minus C
2 minus C 3 so X 1 is equal to minus 1
times C 2 plus C 3 times what plus C 3
times
- one and then what is X 2 equal to X 2
is just equal to C 2 so it's 1 times C 2
plus 0 times C 3 X 3 is just equal to C
3 so it's 0 times C 2 plus 1 times C 3
and so this is another way of defining
our subspace all of the vectors that
satisfy this is equal to is equal to
this definition here it's all the
vectors whose components satisfy or that
lie in this plane whose entries lie in
that plane and that's for any real
numbers right there or another way of
writing that another way of writing this
is that V is equal to the span V is
equal to the span of the vectors minus 1
1 and 0 and the vector minus 1 0 and 1
just like that and we know that these
are actually a basis from V because
they're linearly independent there's no
way I can take linear combinations of
this guy and make the second entry be 1
here and likewise there's no way I can
take linear combinations of this guy and
make this third entry equal to 1 here so
these are also a basis for V so given
that just using the technique we did
before we could set some vector we could
some set some matrix a equal to minus 1
1 0 and then minus 1 0 and 1 and then we
can figure out we can figure out that
the projection of any vector X in r3
onto V is going to be equal to and we
saw this it's going to be equal to a
times the inverse of a transpose a all
of that times a transpose and all of
that times X and you can do it you can
you have a here you can figure out what
the transpose of a is very easy you can
take at a transpose a then you can
invert it and it'll be very similar to
what we did in the last video it'll be a
little less work because this is a 3 by
2 matrix instead of a 4 by 2 matrix but
you saw it
actually a lot of work it's very hairy
and you might make some careless
mistakes so let's think let's let's
figure out if there's another way that
we can come up there's another way that
we can come up with this matrix right
here now we know that if X is a member
we know that if X is a member of r3 that
X can be represented then X can be
represented as a combination of some mem
some vector V that is in our subspace
plus some vector W that is in that is an
R in the art in the orthogonal
complement to the subspace where V V is
a member of our subspace and W is a
member of the orthogonal complement the
orthogonal complement of our subspace
now by definition this is that right
there is the projection of X onto onto V
and this is the projection of X onto the
orthogonal complement of V so we can
write that X X is equal to the
projection onto V of X plus the
projection onto V orthogonal complement
or the orthogonal complement of V of X
so this is by definition that any member
of r3 can really represent it this way
now if we want to write this as matrix
vector products a little and look to
videos ago I showed you that these are
linear transformations so let me write
that here so they're linear
transformation so they can be written as
matrix vector products you see that
right there let me define this matrix I
don't know let me call this let me call
this I don't know let's just call this
matrix T T let me just call it T and let
me call let me call let me do another
let me do a letter now let me do B and
let's say that the projection the
project
of onto the orthogonal complement of V
of X let's say that that's equal to some
other vector
sorry that's some other metric other
matrix C times X we know this is a
linear transformation so it can be
represented as some matrix C times X so
what are these going to be equal to well
X if I want to write it as a linear
transformation of X I could just write
it as the 3 by 3 identity matrix times X
right that's the same thing as X that's
going to be equal to the projection of X
onto V well that's just the same thing
as B times X that's the same thing as B
times X and then plus the projection of
X onto V is orthogonal complement well
that's just C times X plus C times X and
if you want to factor out the X on this
side we know that the matrix vector
products exhibit the distributive
property so we could write that the
identity matrix times X is equal to B
plus C times X or another way to view
this equation is that this matrix must
be equal to these two matrices so we've
get that the identity matrix
the identity matrix in r3 is equal to
the projection matrix onto V plus the
projection matrix onto these orthogonal
complement so if we're trying to
remember the whole point of this problem
is to figure out this thing right here
is to solve for B and we know a
technique for doing it you take a
transpose you do you can do this whole
thing but that might be pretty hairy but
maybe it's easy to find this guy maybe I
don't know it actually turns out in this
video this one will be easy so if it's
easy to find this guy we can just solve
for B we get if we subtract C from both
sides we get that B is equal to is equal
to I is equal to the identity matrix
minus the transformation matrix for the
transformation onto these orthogonal
complement so let's see what this is
let's see if we can figure out what C is
right there so let's go back to our
original so remember let me rewrite the
problem actually remember that V
remember that V was equal to
it's equal to all of the X 1 X 2 s X 3s
that satisfy that satisfy X 1 plus X 2
plus X 3 is equal to 0 or another way to
say it is all the X 1 X 2 s and X 3s
that satisfy the equation 1 1 1 times X
1 X 2 X 3 is equal to the 0 vector or in
this case it'll just be 0 we could write
the zero vector like that just like that
so 1 times X 1 plus 1 times X 2 plus 1
times X 3 is going to equal the 0 vector
this is another way to write V now all
of the X's that satisfy this right here
what is that this this is saying that V
is equal to the null space of this
matrix right there right the null space
of this matrix is all of the vectors
satisfy this equation
so V is equal to the null space the null
space of let me write it this way the
null space of 1 1 1 just like that
up here we kind of figured out V in the
kind of traditional way we figured out
that V is the span of these things but
now we know that's the same thing as the
null space of 1 1 1 these two statements
are equivalent now we at least at a
hunch that maybe you know we could
figure out straight up the this B here
by doing all of this a transpose and you
know by doing all of this silliness here
but our hunch is maybe if we can figure
out the transformation matrix for the
orthogonal complement of V for the
authoritative V right there then that we
can just apply this kind of that we can
this solve for B given that the identity
matrix minus this guy is going to be
equal to
so let's see if we can figure out let's
see if we can figure out the projection
matrix if we can figure out the the
transformation matrix for the orthogonal
projection for X onto the orthogonal
projection of V so this this is V what
is what is V complement the complement
is going to be equal to the orthogonal
complement or V perp is going to be
equal to the orthogonal complement of
the null-space of this of this matrix
right here which is equal to what
remember the null space it's orthogonal
complement then a null space is
orthogonal complement is equivalent to
is equivalent to the row space or the
column space of a transpose we saw that
multiple times or you could say the the
orthogonal complement of the row space
is the null space we've seen this many
many times before so the orthogonal
complement of this guy is going to be
the column space of his transpose so the
column space of the transpose of this
guy right so it's 1 1 1 just like that
or we can write or we can write that V
these orthogonal complement is equal to
the span the span of 1 1 1 right the
column space of this matrix we only have
one column in it so it's column space is
going to be the span of that one column
so just to visualize what we're doing
here that original equation for V that
satisfies that that's just going to be
some plane in r3 that's going to be some
plane in r3 that is V right there and
now we just figured out what these
orthogonal complement is it's going to
be aligned in r3 right is going to be
all of the linear combinations of this
guy so it's going to be some line in r3
I haven't drawn it you know this is
going to be tilted more and so is this
but it's going to be some line so this
is the orthogonal complement of V so
let's see if we can figure out so
remember the projection the projection
let me do it this way so let's create so
this is the basis for these orthogonal
complement
so let's construct some matrix let's
construct some matrix on a limb use a
new letter that I haven't used before
let me construct some matrix D whose
columns are the basis vectors for the
orthogonal complement of V well there's
only one basis vector so it's going to
be that and we learned the last video in
the video before that that the
projection the projection of any vector
in r3 on two V's orthogonal complement
is going to be equal to D times D
transpose D inverse times D transpose
times DS transpose times X or another
way to view it is that this thing right
here that thing right there is the
transformation matrix for this
projection that is the transformation
matrix transformation matrix so let's
see if this is easier to solve this
thing
then this business up here where we had
a three by two matrix that was a whole
motivation for doing this problem to
figure out the projection matrix for the
subspace we'd have to do this with a
three by two matrix it seems pretty
difficult instead let's find the
projection matrix to get to the
projection onto these orthogonal
complement which is this so what is D
transpose so D transpose is just going
to be equal to one one one
what does D transpose times D well
that's D transpose this is D just like
that so what is this going to be equal
to this is just the dot product of that
in that right one times one plus one
times one plus one times one it equals
three so this thing right here is equal
to a one by one matrix three so let's
write down so this is equal to
D D which is this matrix 1 1 1 times D
transpose D inverse so d transpose D is
just a 1 by 1 matrix we have to invert
it actually I've never defined the
inverse of a 1 by 1 matrix for you just
now so this is mildly exciting times D
transpose so D transpose looks like this
1 1 1 and then all of that's times X but
this is the transformation matrix right
there now what is the inverse of a 1 by
1 matrix now you just have to remember
you just have to remember that a inverse
times a is equal to the identity matrix
if we're dealing with a 1 by 1 matrix
then we're just I'm just trying to
figure out what let's say what matrix
times 3 is going to be equal to the 1 by
1 identity matrix so if I say let's say
you know I don't know let's say that 3
inverse 3 inverse times 3 has to be
equal to has to be equal to the identity
matrix 1 by 1 identity matrix well the
only matrix that's going to make this
work out to get the center up to take
this guy's entry times that guy's entry
is going to be this guy right here the
inverse of this 1 by 1 matrix has to be
the matrix 1/3 1/3 times 3 is equal to 1
this is almost trivially simple but this
is the inverse that right there is the
inverse matrix for the 1 by 1 matrix 3
so this right here is just 1/3 and we
could actually just take that out it's a
1 by 1 matrix which is essentially
equivalent to a scalar so this is going
to be equal to this is going to be equal
to let me just draw a line here this
thing is equal to is equal to 1/3
actually I don't want to confuse it let
me rewrite it so we get the projection
the projection of any vector in r3
onto the orthogonal complement of a V is
equal to 1/3 that's 1/3 times the vector
1 1 1 times sorry or way it is a vector
the matrix one on one times that matrix
transpose 1 1 1 and then all of that
times X and you can see this is a lot
simpler than when we did it with when if
we had to do all of this business if we
did all of this business with this
matrix that's a harder matrix to deal
with this 1 1 1 matrix is very easy now
what is this going to be equal to what
is this going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to 1/3 times we have a
3 by 1 times a 1 by 3 matrix so it's
going to result in the 3 by 3 matrix 3
by 3 matrix and what do we get this
first entry is going to be 1 times 1
which is 1 second entries going to be 1
times 1 which is 1 second third entries
gonna be 1 times 1 which is 1 I think
you see the pattern the this guy the
second row first column 1 times 1 is 1
so this is going to be a 3 by 3 matrix
of ones so just like that we were able
to get that was a pretty straightforward
situation we were able to get the
projection matrix for any matrix any
vector in r3 on two V's orthogonal
complement now we just we know that this
is our this thing right here this thing
right here is our original see that we
said now we said that we said that the
identity matrix we did it wrote it up
here let me refer back to what I wrote
way up here we said look the identity
matrix is equal to the transformation
matrix for the product for the
projection onto V plus the
transformation matrix for the projection
onto B's orthogonal complement or we can
write that the transformation matrix for
the projection onto V is equal to the
identity matrix minus the the
transformation matrix for the projection
onto V is orthogonal complement so we
can write so B is our transformation
matrix on to so if we say that the
projection onto V of X is equal to B
times X we know that B is equal to the 3
by 3 identity matrix minus C and this is
C right there
so B
is equal to the identity matrix so
that's just 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 ty minus C
minus 1/3 times 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 just
like that what is this going to be equal
to this is going to be equal to let's
see whenever this is one list in our
heads multiply this out this all of
these entries are going to be one third
essentially if we multiply this out like
that so if we have 1 minus 1/3 right I
could write it out like that's 1/3 1/3
1/3 everything is one-third one-third
one-third one-third one-third one-third
one-third and this just becomes a 1 so 1
minus 1/3 is 2/3 and all of the ones
minus 1/3 are going to be 2/3 so we
could just go down the diagonal and then
the 0 is minus 1/3 are going to be minus
1/3 minus 1/3 minus one third minus 1
third you have minus 1/3 minus 1/3 and
minus 1/3 and just like that we've been
able to figure out our projection or
transformation matrix for the projection
of any vector X onto V by essentially
finding this guy first for finding the
transformation matrix for the projection
of any X onto V S orthogonal complement
anyway that would I thought that was
pretty neat and you could rewrite this
you could rewrite this as be equal to
1/3 times 2 to 2 to s along the
diagonals and then you have minus ones
everywhere else minus ones everywhere
else anyway
see you in the next video